talk to me about know how this is going
to be used today and as we've seen with
all jobs reports used by the Republicans
to speak about their own their own
tactics their own strategy on creating
jobs are they going to use or how are
they going to use a report like this or
can they at all well my guess is Betty
despite the fact that it's Republicans
largely opposed to raising the minimum
wage up on Capitol Hill they're going to
highlight directly both the fact that
there are new wage gains
month-over-month in this report and the
fact that participation rate dropped
down then employments going down they're
going to argue for the wrong reasons
people are leaving the labor force now
again this is so close to election day
the last jobs report before the midterm
election is very hard to argue that this
report is going to make that much
different on Election Day but you can
have Democrats are going to seize on the
the top line numbers here make the cases
the President did yesterday the economy
has started to turn the corner things
are better than a lot of Americans out
there believe even though some people
are still hurting you can have
Republicans say listen this tell us the
similar story that the economy is still
hurting for especially for people who
don't have a job and people who are not
seeing their wages go